le collège juliette dodu
à la fin des années 1930 la réunion
bénéficie d'un prêt de l'état français
qui lui permet de moderniser un grand
nombre d'infrastructures ainsi à la
veille de la seconde guerre mondiale
assistant à une émulation de la
construction publique sur un vaste
terrain qu'elle détient au centre de
saint denis la colonie construit trois
bâtiments la bibliothèque départementale
l'école normale et le lycée de jeunes
filles aujourd'hui collège juliette dodu
l'architecte antoine tellement dessine
une entrée à pans coupés qui épousent
l'angle de la rue
cette entrée de comme les deux
extrémités du bâtiment est légèrement en
saillie les deux façades sont percés de
nombreuses fenêtres animé de fausses
briques et d'éléments décoratifs en
terre cuite vernissée apporter
d'indochine ses façades contraste
fortement avec celle sur cour les larges
galerie de circulation qui desservent
les salles de classe sont rythmées par
des poteaux en béton rappelant ceux de
l'hôtel des thermes à cilaos au début
des années 1960 le lycée devient collège
et se transforme pour faire face au
nombre croissant d'élèves
l'école normale et son jardin font place
à de nouvelles salles de classe et des
équipements sportifs
la nouvelle aile bâti dans le
prolongement du bâtiment donnant sur la
rue sainte marie est caractéristique du
style international
apparu en europe dans les années 1930
le bâtiment construit au centre de la
cour de récréation reprend lui aussi ses
codes architecturaux tout comme le
gymnase que l'on peut aisément admirer
depuis la rue roland-garros